welcome to the show everybody glad to
have you here especially on on this day
which which is a special day around
around here in my house it's my eighth
wedding anniversary eight years of
marriage may not be that much you know
objectively in the grand scheme of
things but by modern standards anyway we
have officially entered old married
couple status which I'm very excited
about and thinking back to that day
eight years ago you know a lot of joy
and hope and promise except the only
problems that there was a torrential
downpour on the day of our wedding you
know we were getting married on the
beach not on the beach physically we're
not hippies we were in a church for
God's sake like like civilized people
but a church at the beach and so the
downpour was flooding roads and
everything and you know was messing up
my wife's hair and her makeup and my
hair and makeup because we're a
progressive couple
but the real problem and anyone who's
gotten anyone who's gotten married in
the last 25 years on a rainy day knows
what I'm about to say the real problem
is the non-stop Alanis Morissette jokes
that just went on for the entire day
and every person who walked into the
church of course they're coming out
there shake it off there you know jacket
and they've got the umbrella and then
they walk into the church and every
single person goes well this is ironic
and then they look around ironic it's
like the Alanis Morissette joke yeah pop
culture reference and like as if they're
the first person to make the joke which
is even more annoying because no rain on
a wedding day of course as many people
have corrected this that is not ironic
it's inconvenient it's a hassle it's not
ironic neither is finding 10,000 spoons
when you're looking for a knife in your
kitchen that's just a sign that somebody
in your house is a degenerate spoon
hoarder it doesn't mean that it's ironic
in any way any case happy Anniversary to
my wife what I what I and to myself I
suppose what I want to begin with today
is a new survey showing that one in
three Millennials have a favorable view
of communism and and this is not the
only survey of this type that's been
done and found results like this and
it's very I think legitimately
terrifying to think that communism is
becoming so popular I want to talk about
that and why it is that my generation
finds
Communism appealing also to Indian
American kids attacked and assaulted a
group of black girls in New Jersey but
the New York Times knows what is really
to blame for this assault white
supremacy I'm not kidding and and also
today speaking on my wedding anniversary
in honor of that occasion I wanted to
talk about the pieces of marriage advice
the common cliched pieces of marriage
advice supposed marriage wisdom that I
have found in my experience so far to be
completely and totally off-base so we'll
talk about that as well
today but first a word from ancestry DNA
ancestry DNA gives you so much more than
just the places that you're from
ancestry connects you to the places in
the world where your story started using
precise Geographic detail and clear-cut
historical insights you can even trace
your ancestors journey over time
following you know following where they
move from place to place and it just it
tells you about yourself I think this is
this is something that in modern society
we've kind of lost this sense of being
connected to our ancestors in our past I
think in times past they wouldn't have
had ancestry they wouldn't have had the
service of an stretch they're doing
doing DNA tests and everything but they
also want to needed it as much because
they had this connection to their past
through the oral history and stories
that were passed on we don't have that
so this is where ancestry day DNA comes
in and to amplify amplify your results
you can start a free trial on ancestry
and build a tree so your ancestors
become more to you than just a name
they've combined a results with over a
hundred million family trees and
billions of records to give you more
insight into your genealogy and your
origins I have sent in my my packet with
from from ancestry I'm looking forward
to finding out what I'm all about what
exactly had to happen to make me occur
who is to blame for this is what I
really want to find out and that's what
I would find out from ancestry go to
ancestry.com slash Matt today for 20%
off your ancestry DNA kit that's
ancestry.com slash Matt for 20% off your
and
sestra DNA kit ancestry.com slash Matt
before we get to the communism thing I
also I forgot about this a priest in
South Carolina I would be I couldn't do
the show without mentioning a priest in
South Carolina reportedly refused
communion to quote-unquote Catholic Joe
Biden father Robert Maury says that he
didn't give Biden communion because
Biden among other things openly
advocates for abortion for the grave sin
known as abortion now I just wanted I
want to say congratulations to this
brave priest for being one of the few
with the guts to actually enforce the
rule and uphold the teaching as it
pertains to this and protecting the
dignity of the sacrament in the church
and not to mention Joe Biden's own soul
he needs this kind of correction for the
sake of his own soul so this was an act
of courage and also mercy I think for
Joe Biden now for those who aren't
familiar the Catholics have the doctrine
of the real presence in the Eucharist
which is the belief that Christ is
really present as it would seem to
indicate really present in the Eucharist
as he said at the Last Supper this is my
body to do this in remembrance of me not
this symbolizes my body but this is my
body do this in remembrance of me that's
where the teaching come from comes from
so people who are in grave sin or in a
state of sin in that way are not
supposed to receive Communion until they
have repented of that sin the Catholic
Church is always taught that abortion is
a grave sin and those who advocate for
it promote it fund it facilitate in it
facilitate it they are guilty of not
only participating in this sin but also
they're guilty of the sin of scandal and
by that we mean we don't mean scandal in
the political sense we mean scandal in
the sense that they are you know you
know encouraging others to fall into sin
in this case explicitly openly
encouraging others so pro-abortion
politicians for that reason are supposed
to be refused Communion it's just that
it rarely happens because priests rarely
have the guts to stand up them to them
also because pro-abortion politicians
rarely go to church in the first place
so to have the opportunity to have
communion refused of them but when they
do go
usually it is disgraceful to note but
usually they'll get communion in no one
withholds it in this case it was
withheld and so I say good for this
priest ok so that's the good news for
today onto some of the bad news the
victims of communism Memorial Foundation
conducts these yearly studies to see how
people's attitudes towards communism are
changing over time and the results of
this year's study this year's study are
truly horrifying I think reading now
from the organization's report here are
what they call the key takeaways some of
the key takeaways anyway I'm
cherry-picking a few of these here that
are special interest cat says capitalism
is still viewed more favorably than
other economic systems holding
relatively steady at sixty-one percent
favorability from 2018 now that's 61
percent overall to me that's pretty low
only 61% of Americans according to this
study are really in favor of capitalism
however favorability of capitalism is
lower among Generation Z and Millennials
at only around 50% down six points and
eight points from 2018 respectively
communism is viewed favorably by more
than one in three Millennials 36 percent
up eight points from 2018 communism by
thirty six percent of Millennials this I
hate to remind you this is the
generation that's taking over the
country they are inheriting the reins of
power when I say they I mean we and 36%
of us are in favor of communism 50% of
Millennials think the world would be
better off if the Soviet Union still
existed
a majority of Americans age 35 and under
trust themselves more than the community
but that's ok so 35 and under a majority
trust themselves 66 percent trust
themselves more than the community or
the government but that means that 34
percent trust the community or the
government more than they trust
themselves think about that while 50
percent of Millennials say they are
somewhat likely and 20 percent of
Millennials say they are extremely
likely to vote for a socialist candidate
doubling from 10 percent in 2018
Americans overall are more hesitant
about voting for a Democrat socialist
than they were last year 45% of
Generation Z and Millennials believe
that okay well obviously naturally 45%
believe that all higher education should
be free on that one I'm actually
surprised that's not higher 45% although
I think the number is trending in the
upward direction now this is all quite
wrong of course I don't mean that the
findings of the study are wrong I think
the findings line up with what you would
expect they ring true to me even though
they're horrifying I mean they're wrong
in that the opinions held by many
Millennials with respect to this issue
and with respect to almost every other
issue you can think of are wrong it
might be too much to ask given that
people don't like to read anymore
especially read long books but if
everyone would just read the first
volume I've recommended this book a
million times if you would just read the
first volume of Solzhenitsyn's Gulag
Archipelago he wrote a three-volume work
talking about his own experience in the
gulag the Soviet gulag but also he kind
of weaves that in to the overall history
of the gulag system in the Soviet Union
it's a fascinating book I've read the
first two volumes haven't read the third
volume yet but it'd be great to read all
of them if you could only read one just
read the first volume and I there's no
way that you could read that book and
come away from it still thinking that a
socialist or communist system is a good
idea I just there's no way you could do
it the these are systems where freedom
liberty self-expression
self-determination human flourishing
human wellbeing are not relevant they
simply don't factor in now the fact that
as government's promise to take care of
everybody and make sure that and make
sure that everyone's needs are provided
for and then fail always every single
time to follow through on that promise
is almost beside the point
because what happens when we have this
conversations people say well I look at
the bread lines in Venezuela or the
empty grocery shelves and this is
supposed to prove the faults of this
kind of system but even though it's true
that that does indicate serious problems
the social system I think that's the
wrong approach just observing all the
bad things that have happened under
communist and socialist governments is
not enough clearly now when I
recommended the Gulag Archipelago
it's not because it chronicles all the
bad stuff which it does and does so
powerfully importantly the real powerful
thing about the book I think is how it
exposes the philosophical flaws with
this system and that's what we need to
focus on communicating is the
philosophical problem with it we need to
focus on why it's a bad idea not just
why it's bad in practice not just why
not not not just the practical problems
even if they are significant practical
problems such as mass starvation is a
practical problem pretty significant one
I would think but that clearly has not
been even if it should be enough for
people to be convinced it's not enough
and the reason is there's always a
defense mechanism that's that you know
this defense in mechanism that has been
built up and it's a pretty effective
mechanism and that mechanism that
strategy is the classic move of saying
well hey communism is a great idea but
it's just that it's usually not done
right and when you point to an example
of a communist or socialist regime
Venezuela China Soviet Union wherever
that where there's been horrific results
you could always say well that's not
real communism or that's not real
socialism or there's the more skeptical
sounding version of this where somebody
says communism is great in theory just
bad in practice
that no it's bad in theory and the
reason why it's always bad in practice
is because it's bad in theory and so we
need to talk about that theory here's is
the other thing that people need to
understand about Millennials and I guess
gen Generation Z I don't know anything
about those people but even though I
guess my kids are in that group I don't
know but here's what I think some people
miss about Millennials the arguments and
not just with with this issue with with
the economics but with any issue the are
the arguments that really speak to
Millennials are going to be
philosophical moral arguments which in
some ways I would say is a credit to my
generation that were a little bit less
focused on the practical implications of
things which there's a downside to that
which we're seeing but they're a little
less focused on that and a little more
focused on the moral argument like what
what's the right thing to do okay and
this this is a fact about Millennials if
everyone seems to miss I how can you
miss it and so this is why the messaging
by conservatives to Millennials has so
often fails because when you start
talking about the practical stuff of uh
you know you want a job you want this
that's no that's not that's not how
you're gonna speak to them notice you
notice what Bernie Sanders does what
Elizabeth Warren does where all the
democrats do especially when it comes to
economic stuff much to the frustration
of conservatives they're not making
practical arguments they're not
explaining how their plans are actually
going to work because the plans aren't
going to work but from a messaging
standpoint it doesn't matter because
instead what they're doing is they're
saying this is just the right thing it's
the right thing to do and they're making
that moral argument it's a bad moral
argument but it is a moral
argument and a philosophical argument so
I think here's here's what it comes down
to the core the fundamental questions
that pertain to this what is the point
of living what are we supposed to get
out of life what's the function of a
person what what are people for to quote
a Wendell Berry essay yes the theory of
communism is to care for and provide for
everyone equally it never works out that
way but never mind that for a minute
let's just talk about the theory the
problem is that's not what people are
for that is not the most moral system
even if it worked which it doesn't
because we are not as people just like
pigs in a pen where you give us food and
maybe you clean out the pen every once
in a while and then you leave us to muck
around in the mud in our in our little
safe confines that's not what how people
work we are human beings
thinking striving dreaming rational
creatures which means in order for us to
actually be happy in order for us to
really be fulfilled in order for us to
flourish we need the Liberty to act on
our own make our own decisions express
our own views work towards our own goals
care for ourselves this isn't to say the
community is unimportant it just means
that we are communities of humans not of
ants or bees and communism is great for
ants and bees because it emphasizes the
community completely at the expense of
the individual where the individual
basically doesn't exist and doesn't
matter
that doesn't work for creatures that
literally have hive minds that's great
for human beings it's not so great and I
think that has to be our message the
reason
my communism is so appealing to younger
people is that as I've argued there's
way too much focus on the practical
pitfalls of communism which which leaves
open this idea that in theory it's great
and someone just has to figure out how
to make it work because it's the most
moral system and it's a system that's
gonna make people the happiest and so we
should do it if we could
and also because before even making the
point that communism destroys liberty
which is the main point the real reason
to oppose it but before even getting
there people need first to actually
desire liberty and freedom and and
herein lies I think the real problem a
lot of younger people today just don't
have that desire for liberty for freedom
for independence because it hasn't been
instilled in them and that's what we
need to work on getting people to
understand especially young people why
freedom is a beautiful and necessary
thing and something that will ultimately
make them happy and fulfilled and why it
is the most moral thing you know why it
is better to have a system where people
are free and they have
self-determination even if you have
things like poverty and so on you know I
I I knew we had a problem when I started
seeing when it comes to this well you
know you started seeing these reports in
the last few years about how kids are
driving and later in later ages they're
putting off getting their licenses
because they're content to be
chauffeured around by their parents and
it's a small thing but it's illustrative
because it used to be that kids couldn't
wait to get their licenses right because
they want to be able to get out on their
own hit the open road have some
independence have some autonomy I
remember I was so excited get my license
and I just the the idea of being able to
get in my car and go run an errand or
something even even something as simple
as that but just if I if I needed
something from the store if I needed to
go that I can just get in the car and go
do it myself without help without having
to depend on anybody that to me I
couldn't wait to do that I was so
excited to run my first errand that as
an adult but
that's that's something that kids today
this a desire they don't seem to have
quite as much you know and in a similar
way used to be that you'd be excited to
leave your home once you were old enough
and live on your own get out on your own
even if you end up living in some dingy
apartment or whatever even if your
living conditions are downgraded in some
respects from what you had at your
parents place you loved it because it
was yours it was your space you could do
what you wanted it was your thing you
were basically free to live as you
wanted but younger people don't desire
that anymore either which continues to
be shocking to me just I can't I can't
wrap my head around that mentality
because I wanted to move out when I was
16 not because I had a miserable home
life but just because I wanted to be on
my own I was just I was just tired of I
wanted to do my own thing but now you've
got 26 year olds who don't really have
that desire they don't really want to do
their own thing so it's and again with
something like that if you want to make
an argument to people that hey you know
you should get your license and you
should move out of the house and live on
your own I think it's important to have
the younger generation doing that and
learning how to live independently and
learning that independence is a good
thing but if you're gonna make that
argument once again you can't really
make it on practical grounds because in
a way as opposed to with something like
communism the-the-the the very sort of
localized communism of a of an adult
that still lives at home with his
parents and it's taken care of by the
government of the house which would be
their parents that does make in a
practical way I mean it does make some
practical sense because you're saving
money and all of that so in a way
practically speaking yeah I can see why
you would do it but there's more of a
philosophical argument it's a
philosophical argument for why even
though it makes practical sense you
still shouldn't do it because it's it's
not because that's not how
you are going to flourish as a human
being you'll be more comfortable that
way but you're not gonna be happiest
you're not gonna flourish you're not
gonna become yourself figure out who you
are come of age mature none of that's
gonna happen if you're still depending
on your parents so I think these are the
kinds of argument we make and and if we
start doing this but I think that's how
we get people to abandon this idea that
communism is the way to go all right
well we've been dumping on the
Washington Post for mourning the death
of the great mass murdering serial
rapist scholar al Baghdadi
but I think the New York Times deserves
as always a share of the ridicule this
week we shave if we're making fun of the
media we should always include the New
York Times because they're always giving
us more and more reasons to make fun of
them I point now to an article an op-ed
published a couple days ago which no
matter how cynical you are about the
media you might not even believe this is
real you'll probably you're probably
going to look this up and google it to
see if it actually exists which I
encourage you to do but it is real it
does exist it's by Nell Irvin painter
and it's an op-ed about an assault on a
group of black girls by two Indian boys
Indian American boys but painter knows
who is really to blame for this white
people so listen to this she says in the
pages of the New York Times two
seventeen year old boys accused of
harassing four african-american middle
school middle school girls using racial
slurs and urinating on one of the
victims are facing charges including
bias intimidation and lewdness the
incident which took place during an
October 18th high school football game
of the New Jersey suburb of Lawrence
Township and was partly captured on
video that circulated on social media
involves a cast of characters that have
given some observers pause
police say the boys are of Indian
descent while it's tempting to see the
reported ethnicity of the boys suspected
in the assault as complicating the story
and raising questions about whether the
assault should be thought of as racist I
look at it through a different lens
instead of asking what let me just stop
here actually first with one second it
actually doesn't complicate the story at
all and it doesn't
raise questions about whether or not
it's racist there's nothing to for those
for rational people to see a non-white
person acting in a bigoted way to
another non-white person that's not
complicated that doesn't raise questions
of whether it's racist
it's very uncomplicated that's racist
because as rational people we understand
that racism obviously exists among all
people not just white people but the
author here doesn't seem to agree so she
says instead of asking what the boys
reported racial identity tells us about
the nature of the attack we should see
the boys as an act listen listen
carefully is we should see the boys as
enacting American whiteness through anti
black assault in a very traditional way
in doing so the assailants are
demonstrating how race is a social
construct that people make through their
actions they show race in the making and
show how race is something we perform
not just something we are in our blood
or in the color of our skin enacting
whiteness by assaulting someone no
matter what race you are you are
enacting whiteness why well because
white people the only ones who are
racist but you see the circular logic
here you know when when a non-white
person
assaults another not a person that has
to be racist why because white people
are the only ones who are racist so you
see how the the circle goes every every
racist incident is by a white person or
white people are to blame for it and so
when you have a racist incident that
doesn't involve white people well know
it but still involve white people
because white people only wants it could
be racist and we just go around around
in that circle of logic or anti logic I
guess we should call it let's see she
could sue we read any more of this at
first blush the reported assault sounds
nauseatingly familiar like the
run-of-the-mill American racial
harassment that
it's been always a bit in common but has
become increasingly revealed thanks to
videos shared on social media
the boys actions resemble those of
people who feel empowered to act out
their resentment against non-white
people who are deemed out of place
confronting them with hostility or slurs
or calling the police
the people patrolling what they see as
their spaces are often but not always
white the Yale sociologist Elijah
Anderson calls areas that are policed in
this way the white space even though the
spaces in question are officially public
so just the understand what's happening
here
when someone is assaults or abuses
another person in a space the person who
is doing the assaulting in the blue
abusing is defending the white space
even if they're not white they have now
become I don't know if it's a Manchurian
Candidate kind of thing where we as
white people have brainwashed them to
enforce our space whatever that is
there's someone in the white space get
them I don't know they imagine that
we're you know we were whispering that
into a microphone and it's something
that you know a chip implanted in their
ear and they're following our orders
hypnotized I don't know what they
imagine how this works but but that's
basically the result and then it goes on
from there anyway I think you've
probably heard enough you get the idea
this is I think it should be noted that
I looked up this author's biography and
seeing what it says here it won't
surprise you that this is someone from
academia I don't know if they're still
in academia but someone who was in in
academia this is what you send your kids
to a mainstream college to a major you
know secular kind of college what I mean
this is the kind of thing they're being
taught as fact
so this is
hyperbole or me being satirical or
anything they the left really believes
that only white people can be racist by
definition and so any racist thing that
happens has to be the fault of white
people that is actually what they
believe that is actually what they teach
to kids as a fact in school and it of
course is completely insane and has no
basis in reality and it entirely ignores
the fact and in fact is meant to
obfuscate the fact that the bigotry and
so-called intolerance and racial hatred
is extremely pervasive and common all
across the world and very often is much
more common and much more pervasive and
much more violent and aggressive and
dangerous in non-white parts of the
world but that's the fact that we're not
supposed to notice that okay as I
mentioned today is my wedding
anniversary eight years and I thought it
could be fun possibly instructive to go
over some of the very common and cliched
bits of marriage wisdom that that
everyone hears before marriage but I
have found to be completely off-base and
wrong in my experience and anyone who's
contemplating marriage if you're younger
and you're thinking about getting
married or you just got married
hopefully this will be instructive for
you now I don't know what your
particular experience is going to be but
I I think probably these are bits of
advice that you've already heard a bunch
of times and in my opinion you should
just discard and forget about okay so
we'll go through some of these number
one never go to bed angry this is
terrible advice it's very common you
hear
all the time and I really believed
before I got married and I heard never
go to bed angry so I thought okay well
guess you can't go to bed angry what
I've discovered though and you discover
this pretty quickly is that if you're
ticked off at each other around bedtime
which does happen hopefully doesn't
happen that often but it does happen
especially you've had a long day and
you've got kids and all that and the
kids are being kids and just at the end
of day you're exhausted and everything
and you're getting on each other's
nerves you get into it into a fight
well ok you have two options at that
point you it's it's around bedtime
you're angry
two options you can fight it out into
the wee hours of the morning and then
probably still in the end go to bed
angry or just get some sleep and sleep
it off
wake up in the morning and ninety
percent of time discover that you don't
even care anymore you're not angry
anymore
the latter option is better almost all
the time so this this is almost
completely the opposite of the case also
you know I I have personally found that
screaming at your spouse no don't fall
asleep
we can't go to bed angry that doesn't
really work to calm things down I've
discovered anger subsides on it on its
own you can't demand that someone stop
being angry it's just on its own it goes
away and most of the time in a marriage
depending on how serious the fight is I
mean you know if it's something very
serious this will this isn't true but
the vast majority of the argument that
you have in a marriage are not serious
and it's about something that doesn't
really matter that much and you're both
kind of wrong but you're also both kind
of right you have your good points and
your bad points that's that's the
majority of arguments and so but when
you're in the midst of it and you're
angry you just you can't see that you go
to bed you wake up and you'll see that
oh man
now if you if you cut it off at the past
and decide not to have the argument and
you just go to bed you'll wake up and
think about all the things because yeah
you went to bed angry
so as you're falling asleep you're
stewing over it and you're you're
thinking about all the things you
you could be saying right now you're
thinking about waking up your spouse to
say these great points that you you
think you want to make but when you
eventually you do fall sit you wake up
in the morning you think yourself thank
God I didn't say I knew that that's a
very good thing
so um definitely go to bed angry
sometimes that's my first so that's how
I respond to number two people say the
first year is the hardest I I don't know
who came up with this I have to assume
that the the person who came up with it
is someone who got divorced after the
first year this is someone who couldn't
hack it at all and got divorced and then
figured that well first here must be the
artist because it was my only year so
what do I know the first year is
actually a piece of cake barring some
kind of extenuating circumstance that
makes your particular situation very
difficult in most cases on the sort of
standard first year model of marriage it
is a piece of cake there's it's you
don't have kids probably you're just
it's just the two of you and you just
got married you're doing your thing it's
just it's no problem
it's it's not until later when the kids
come and you got the bills and and and
and you've got just all the challenges
and the vicissitudes of fortune to use a
phrase that I use quite commonly in my
household it's with all that that you
start having the challenges and and
that's when you have the more difficult
moments
I think telling people that the first
year is the hardest just sets them up
for failure by giving them a false
confidence where they get through the
first year they look back at her they
say really that's the hardest it's gonna
get you kidding me there's a piece of
cake and then and then the first time
they hit a real speed bump everything
falls apart because they weren't they
weren't expecting that number three
people say you know never keep anything
from your partner don't keep anything
yourself now this is true if if the
point is that you shouldn't like hi to
money or have affairs or something like
that
then and with the money thing now that
that is a cliched common piece of advice
about don't have separate accounts and
don't do that
that I think is 100 percent correct it's
absolutely true you get you let money
come
between you and a marriage and you both
have your own money that's that you're
just asking for your @u a base you might
as well be literally asking for a
divorce at that point you might as well
cut to the chase and just it just asked
for the divorce because yeah that's
where you're headed if you if you're
letting money come between you and
marriage like that but with the
exception of those kinds of things the
way this is often translated when people
say don't keep anything from your spouse
the way it's translated in a marriage a
lot of the time is that you should
always share your feelings and your
concerns with your spouse all the time
never hold anything back or keep
anything to yourself and that's that is
definitely wrong it couldn't be more
wrong now I'm someone on Twitter very I
was talking about this on Twitter last
night someone on Twitter very wisely
described this I wish I could steal this
and pretend that I came up with us but
but I didn't someone said that this is
like using your spouse as an emotional
toilet it is the emotional toilet
approach to marriage and that is you're
just you're you're dumping all of your
emotional baggage on your spouse
vomiting out all the complaints and
miseries of the day not because you want
to bond with them or share with them but
just because you're trying to unload and
you don't want to have it and so it just
makes you feel better to get it all out
there you're trying to vent a good rule
of thumb I think is this if you have to
justify what you're saying by qualifying
it with I'm just venting you probably
should have kept it to yourself I think
90% of the time what you feel the need
to excuse by calling it venting is
something that you that you were selfish
for saying in the first place because
you're taking your own miseries and
you're dumping them on your spouse just
backing up the dump truck and unloading
it here you go go scream into a pillow
if you if you need to but your spouse is
not a pillow to be screamed into the
number-four marriage is 50/50 this is I
think obviously now I before go and
we're going into marriage I knew that
this was this was BS marriages fit
marriages
not 5050 you can't split everything down
the line 50/50 if you try to do that
it's kind of like the money thing it's
you you are marching right to the
divorce attorney if you're trying to
have a marriage like that if you're
trying to be like my kids the twins who
are continent because they're six years
old so they insist that everything is
exactly equal you know they start
measuring oh you gave him a little bit
more cereal than me that kind of thing
that's you give them both a cookie and
they hold the cookies up to see who has
a little bit more cookie than the other
then they're the one with less cookie
demands to be compensated for the cookie
they're missing out on if you if okay
it's one thing if your six-year-old
child operating that way but if you're
trying to have a marriage that way it's
just not gonna work what I would also
say though because it's common for
people to say oh no marriages aren't
5050 they're 100 100 in that you're both
giving a hundred percent of the hundred
percent all the time I think that's also
wrong that is also bad advice or maybe
it's not so much bad advice as it is an
unrealistic expectation that you are
giving to a married couple when you say
that because even if it's true that in
an ideal world both spouses should be
giving a hundred percent all the time
that's not how it's ever going to work
and so in certain areas of your marriage
and in the family and in the household
you know the husband is going to be
doing 85 percent and the wife is doing
15 and there are other areas where the
wife is doing 92 and the husband is
doing 8 and they're even going to be
times when one spouse is doing 100 the
other one is doing 0 that's just how it
works and and I think the point is you
can't measure it when you're sitting
there trying to measure whether you're
trying to measure 50 or trying to
measure a hundred if you're measuring at
all and you're comparing like that it
you're setting yourself up once again
for failure it's just that a marriage
can't work that way and I also think
actually that I think it's really
important in a marriage especially when
their kids aren't involved it's
important that both
spouses get chances sometimes to do 0 so
I think as a spouse you should be
volunteering to do a hundred sometimes
so your spouse can go do 0 for a little
bit have some me time have some time to
themselves away from the kids away from
you away from the house just just live
being a you know being a their own human
for a few hours I think that's extremely
important and talking to a lot of
married couples it seems like there are
a lot of people in marriages where
they're never get that never they're
never given a chance to go and just do 0
because they all we because their
spouses attitude as always hey if I'm in
the midst of it then you got to be here
too you're not yeah you're not getting a
break if I don't get one at the same
time that is a lethal attitude I think
and then number five the fifth piece of
bad advice is people say this comes in
different forms but people say happy
wife happy life you know this is another
one that could be interpreted in a
positive good healthy way if what you
mean is that you should try to look out
for your spouse's happiness generally
then sure although wives should be doing
that for their husbands too now I know
it doesn't rhyme as well so you know
happy wife happy life it's a nice little
Ryan there happy husband happy I don't
know what would rhyme with husband that
means life I'm not sure anything does
but both spouses should be looking out
for the other person's happiness which
isn't to say that spouses should be
dependent on the other for their
happiness but voluntarily we in a
marriage should be wanting to do what we
can to help our spouse be happy the
problem is that the way this offer gets
translated is that the husband should
just give the wife what she wants always
agree never argue with her etc etc yada
yada and this idea is communicated in a
variety of half-joking but not really
joking at always like happy life happy
wife or happy wife happy life or where
someone says something like you know the
most important words for a husband to
learn in a marriage are yes dear
anything in that vein
all the stuff about how the wife is
always right and this is something I
heard before my marriage constantly the
guys will come up to me and they would
say well the best advice I can give this
she's always right and then they kind of
that thing where they're half whispering
but not really the best advice I can
give us she's always right now first of
all this strikes me as enormous ly
patronizing to women where you're just
patting your wife on the head and saying
it there there yeah you're right honey
okay but more to the point it's an
absolutely pathetic way for a man to
approach marriage and it's hard for me
to believe that any woman actually
respects a pushover like that there
might be a part of them that likes it
because they get their way but they
don't respect you if they can if they
can walk all over you they're not gonna
respect you women don't want yes men
they just want men here's the fact of
the matter wives and this is a news
flash breaking news here wives are not
always right sometimes they're wrong
in fact a wife is just as likely to be
wrong as a husband because you're both
fallible human beings you're not perfect
she's not perfect nobody's perfect so
she can be wrong it does happen
and when she is wrong as the husband you
should tell her now doesn't mean should
scream at her or be condescending about
it but if she's wrong about something
which you should say so and if it starts
an argument and you're in the right then
then hold your ground
you don't even have to give up just to
just to try to keep the peace or
whatever if your wife's happiness hinges
on always being agreed with and getting
everything she wants all the time then
she needs to grow up okay your wife is
an emotional child in that case and you
can help that process by being a grown
man yourself because you are also an
emotional child in that you have allowed
your marriage to become this but
hopefully your wife is like mine my wife
is a grown woman she's an adult she can
not only handle being disagreed with but
she very much prefers it over being
played
with a head nod now I generally have no
reservations maybe doesn't surprise you
but I have no reservations generally
with with disagreeing and this this can
go you can go overboard with disagreeing
I'll be the first to admit that and
there are times when you know pick your
battles that old there there's there's a
cliche that does come and come into play
I think in marriage and parenting you do
have to pick your battles sometimes you
can't fight everything to the death all
the time and so there are going to be
times when yeah you think you're kind of
right but it doesn't matter that much
and so and so okay you're not gonna
you're not gonna have out over this so
there are gonna be times like that but
even in those times and my point is you
just your whole marriage can't be that
way every once in a while okay but even
in those times when I when you know I'm
you have a disagreement with my wife and
and so but I think it's not a big deal
so I'll just say okay whatever
usually what my wife will say is if
something like okay do you actually
agree with me or are you just saying
that because you don't want to fight she
doesn't she's not gonna accept that she
wants to hear what I actually think even
if it's not a big deal she really wants
to know what I think about it so um I
would say if you're a man getting
married I hope that you end up with a
wife like that who's a grown woman as so
many are but if she isn't if she's
emotionally immature and she breaks down
into tears when you stand up to her and
this there that exists too there are men
in situations like that
I have heard well if that's the case I'm
sorry for your misfortune on that score
I do not envy your position but you
aren't gonna make the situation better
by letting her heard you along like
cattle and just giving her everything
you want it's only gonna get worse it's
gonna get worse and she is gonna become
more and more miserable so while you're
trying to make her happy she's not gonna
be happy and you're gonna be miserable
and everyone's miserable and then
eventually you get divorced that's the
way it's gonna work better to you know
nip that in the bud right away and and
and actually just be an adult and if you
you know stand up and voice your opinion
and all of that and there are so many
things like you know also related to
this is the
meme about husband's going off to sleep
on the couch when their wife is mad at
them I don't even know if that's real
like that's I don't I'm not sure if
that's something from a sitcom or if
people actually do that it doesn't
happen in my house and it didn't happen
in with my parents so I've never seen it
but you hear about it and it this is
kind of related to the hey she's always
right just say just say yes dear that's
another one where if that actually is
happening I mean if you're a man and
you're letting your wife put you in
timeout like a like a schoolboy on the
couch I can't even imagine how that
conversation works like okay so she's
mad at you for whatever reason
you're going to sleep and what did she
say no mister you're not getting in this
bed downstairs you go and you actually
listen and you say okay may I bring a
sheet and a blanket with me will that be
okay ma'am can I know you get in the bed
you say listen this this is my bed too
I'm sleeping here if you don't like it
you can go sleep on the couch I'm not
gonna sleep on the couch if you're the
one with the problem doesn't want to be
near me go sleep on the couch yourself
I'm not so that's how I would those are
but I I would be interested I really
want to know he is that really a thing
are there guys who actually do that
allow yourself to be kicked out of your
own bed or is that just something from
Kevin James sitcoms I'd really like to
know that and I'd also like to know what
what are the if you're a married couple
what are the pieces of advice that you
have found to be very very incorrect and
off base in your own experience Matt
wall show at gmail.com is email address
and we will cut it off there thanks
everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey
everybody its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show you know some people
are depressed because the American
Republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]